so my story starts on July forest 1992
the day my mother followed her college
sweetheart to New York City from Egypt
as fireworks exploded behind the skyline
my father looked at my mother jokingly
and said look happy Americans are
celebrating your arrival unfortunately
it didn't feel much like a celebration
when growing up my mother and I would
wander past Queens into New York City
streets and my mother with her hijab and
long flowy dresses would tie in her hand
around my small fingers and she as she
stood up against weathered comments like
go back to where you came from learn
English stupid immigrant these words
were meant to make us feel safe unsafe
insecure in our own neighborhoods in our
own skin but it was these same streets
that made me fall in love with New York
Queens is one of the most diverse places
in the world with immigrant parents
holding stories that always start with
something between three and fifteen
dollars in a pocket a voyage across a
vast sea and a cash-only hustle
sheltering families and jam-packed
busted apartments and it was these same
families that worked so hard to make
sure that we had safe micro communities
we as immigrant children to feel
affirmed and loved in our identities but
it was mostly the women and these women
are the reason why regardless of these
statements that my mom faced she
remained unapologetic and these women
were some of the most powerful women I
have ever met in my entire life I mean
they had networks for everything they
had rotations for who watched whose kids
when for saving extra cash for throwing
belly dance parties and memorizing Quran
and learning English and they would
collect small gold tokens to fundraise
for the local mosque and it was these
same women when I decided to wear my
hijab who supported me through it and
when I was bullied for being Muslim
I always felt like I had an army of
unapologetic North African auntie's who
had my back and so every morning at 15 I
would wake up and stand in front of a
mirror and wrap beautiful bright silk
around my head
the way my mother does and my
grandmother did and one day that summer
2009 I stepped out into the streets of
New York City on my way to volunteer at
a domestic violence organization that a
woman in my neighborhood had started and
I remember at that moment I felt a Yank
at the back of my head then someone
pulled and grabbed me trying to remove
my head job from us was my head I turned
around to a tall broad-shouldered man
pure hate in his eyes I struggled and
fought back and finally was able to get
away hid myself in the bathroom of that
organization and cried and cried I kept
thinking to myself why does he hate me
he doesn't even know me hate crimes
against Muslims in the u.s. increased by
1600 percent
post 9/11 and one in every four women in
the u.s. will form some form of gendered
violence and it may not seem like it but
Islamophobia and anti-muslim violence is
a form of gender violence given the
visibility of Muslim women in our hijabs
and so I was not alone and that
horrified me it made me want to do
something it made me want to go out
there and make sure that no one I love
that no woman would have to feel this
insecure in her own skin so I started to
think about how the women in my own
neighborhood were able to build
community for themselves and how they
were able to use the very little
resources they had to actually offer
something and I began to think about
what I could potentially offer to build
safety and power for women and through
this journey I learned a couple of
things and this is what I want to share
with you today some of these lessons so
lesson number one start with what you
know at the time I had been doing
Shotokan Karate for as long as I could
remember and so I had a black belt yeah
and so I thought who's surprised I
thought that maybe I should go out into
my neighborhood
and teach self-defense to young girls
and so actually went out and knocked on
doors spoke to community leaders to
parents to young women and finally was
able to secure secure a free community
center basement and convince enough
young women that they should come to my
class and it was actually like it
actually all worked out because when I
pitched the idea most of the responses
were like all right cute this five foot
one inch hijab' girl who knows karate
how nice but in reality I became the
Queens New York version of mr. Miyagi at
16 years old and I started teaching
thirteen young women in that community
center community center basement self
defense and with every single
self-defense move for eight sessions
over the course of that summer we began
to understand the power of our bodies
and we began to share our experiences
about our identities and in one and
sometimes there were shocking
realizations and other times there were
tears but mostly it was laughs and I
entered that summer with this incredible
sisterhood and I began to feel much
safer in my own skin and it was because
of these women that we just kept
teaching I never thought that I would
continue but we just kept teaching and
today 9 years 17 cities 12 countries 760
courses and thousands of women and girls
later I'm still teaching and what
started as a self-defense course in a
basement of a community center is now an
international grassroots organization
focused on building safety and power for
women around the world Malika
now for lesson number two start with who
you know often times it could be quite
exciting especially if you're an expert
in something and you want to have impact
to swoop in to a community and think you
have the magic recipe but very early on
I learned that as esteemed philosopher
Kendrick Lamar once said it's really
important to be humble and to sit down
so basically at 15 years old the only
community that I had any business doing
work with were the fourteen-year-old
girls in my neighborhood and that's
because I was friends with them other
than that I didn't know what it meant to
be a child of Bengali immigrants in
Brooklyn or to be Senegalese in the
Bronx but I did know young women who
were connected to those communities and
it was quite remarkable how they already
had these layers of trusts and awareness
and relationship with their communities
so like my mother and the women in her
neighborhood they had these really
strong social networks and it was about
giving providing capacity and believing
in other woman's definition of safety
even though I was a self-defense
instructor I couldn't come into a
community and define safety for any
other women who is not part of my own
community and it was because as our
network expanded I learned that
self-defense is not just physical it's
actually really emotional work I mean we
would do a 60-minute
self-defense class and then we have 30
minutes reserved for just talking and
healing and in those 30 minutes
women would share what brought them to
the class to begin with but also various
other experiences with violence and as
an example one time in one of those
classes one woman actually started to
talk about the fact that she had been in
a domestic violence relationship for
over 30 years and it was her first time
being able to articulate that because we
had established that safe space for her
so it's powerful work but it only
happens when we believe in women's
agency to define what safety and what
power looks like for themselves all
right for lesson number three and this
was the hardest thing for me the most
important thing about this work is to
start with the joy when
started doing this work I was reacting
to a hate based attack so I was feeling
insecure and anxious and overwhelmed I
was really afraid and it makes sense
because if you take a step back and I
can imagine that a lot of women in this
room could probably relate to this the
feeling and overwhelming feeling of
insecurity is oftentimes with us
constantly
I mean imagine this walking home late at
night hearing footsteps behind you you
wonder if you should walk faster
a few should slow down you keep your
keys in your hand in case you need to
use them you say text me when you get
home I want to make sure you are safe
and we mean those words we're afraid to
put down our drinks we're afraid to
speak too much or too little in a
meeting and imagine being women
and black and trans and queer and lion X
and undocumented and poor an immigrant
and you could then only imagine how
overwhelming this work can be especially
within the context of personal safety
however when I took a step to reflect on
what brought me to this work to begin
with I began to realize it was actually
the love that I had for women in my
community it was the ability the way I
saw them gather their ability to build
for each other that inspired me to keep
doing this work day in and day out so
whether I was in a refugee camp in
Jordan or a community center in Dallas
Texas or a corporate office in Silicon
Valley women gathered in beautifully
magical ways and they built together and
supported each other and ways that
shifted culture to empower and build
safety for women and that is how the
change happens it was through those
relationships we built together that's
why we don't just teach self-defense but
we also throw dance parties and host
potlucks and write write love notes to
each other
and sing songs together and it's really
about the friendship and it's been so so
fun so the last thing I want to leave
you is is that the key point of me the
key takeaway for me in teaching self
defense all of these years is that I
actually don't want women as cool as the
self defense moves are to go out and use
these self-defense techniques I don't
want any woman to have to have to
de-escalate any violent situation but
that to happen the violence shouldn't
happen and for the violence not to
happen the systems and the cultures that
allow for this violence to take place to
begin with needs to stop and for that to
happen we need all hands on deck so I've
given you my secret recipe MMH and now
it's up to you to start with what you
know to start with who you know and to
start with joy but just start thank you
so much
[Applause]